Thongo lam vum
Thongo lam vuma
Lam vuma
Lam vuma, lam vuma
(Improvisation)
(Fin de la chanson)
(Applaudissements)
Bonjour à tous !
Merci beaucoup de nous recevoir ici.
Je m'appelle Thandiswa Mazwai.
Je suis une femme sauvage, une chanteuse rebelle, une messagère.
Ma musique traite des mémoires
et du combat entre l'oppression et la liberté.
Après plus de 20 ans en Afrique du Sud,
nous, toute la communauté noire,
souffrons et combattons encore pour notre liberté et humanité.
La première chanson s’appelait « Iyeza » qui signifie « remède ».
Remède contre notre folie, Remède contre notre colère
Celle que nous allons chanter maintenant s'appelle « Zabalaza »
qui signifie « Révolté ».
J'aimerais la dédier au brave mouvement étudiant d'Afrique du Sud
qui est à l'origine de #FeesMustFall
(Applaudissements)
#RhodesMustFall
Mais plus important,
la nouvelle détermination dans le mouvement féministe,
donc la patriarchie doit tomber.
(Applaudissements)
(Musique)
Gogo bek' umthwalo
Kunin' uhlupheka ?
Little ghetto child (Petit enfant du ghetto)
Ungazibulali sana
Oh ...
Si tu prends ma main,
Je te montrerais
comment être libre.
Ayifanelang' ub' iyenzeka lento
Emzini kabawo
kunge kudala
Sizozabalaza.
Zabalaza, zabalaza.
Zabalaza.
Sizozabalaza.
Zabalaza, zabalaza.
Zabalaza.
(Vocalisation)
(Improvisation)
C'est mon peuple à Soweto,
C'est mon peuple en Mozambique,
mon peuple au Sénégal.
C'est mon peuple dans les ghettos.
Zabalaza, zabalaza.
Zabalaza.
(Fin de la chanson)
(Applaudissements)
(Acclamations)
Merci infiniment.
(Applaudissements)